>> Laura: TOP FEDERAL
PROSECUTOR IN MASSACHUSETTS
DEFENDED I.C.E. AGENTS WHO
ARRESTED A SUSPECT OUTSIDE THE
COURTHOUSE.
EVEN THOUGH THE JUDGE WAS
OUTRAGED.
JOINING US NOW TO EXPLAIN WHAT
HAPPENED IS ANDREW MEHLING U.S.
ATTORNEY FOR THE DISTRICT OF
MASSACHUSETTS.
THIS STORY IS WILD, PEOPLE WERE
STUNNED BY THIS.
WE HAVE A JUDGE, WHO IS AN OBAMA
APPOINTEE, REALLY UPSET WHEN AN
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT WHO IS A
CHINESE NATIONAL WAS ACTUALLY
CONVICTED OF A FEW DIFFERENT
FELONIES AND THUS BECOMES
IMMEDIATELY DEPORTABLE AS AN
ALIEN, TELL US HOW IT WENT DOWN
IN THE COURTROOM.
>> SHE WAS SENTENCING THIS
DEFENDANT FOR COMMITTING VISA
AND PASSPORT FRAUD IN THE COURSE
OF TAKING THE GRE AND OTHER
EXAMS FOR PEOPLE IN THE